Jonathan Fagan from the Houston
Chronicle the Rockets reporter joining
us on the program Jonathan thanks for
joining us what did you see differently
last night than you have in prior games
with the Rockets against the Warriors
well actually more like the prior games
other than Game one of rockets versus
Warriors where the Rockets were very
aggressive defensively switching not
just seamlessly but kind of with a
purpose to where they were disruptive
defensively and then that triggers so
much more about their offense than when
they were play after play walking it
down and sort of in a measure of attack
that was more of what we saw in the
regular season games Rockets versus
Warriors and Rockets in the majority of
their 65 wins
so they got kind of back to what they
had been before and that they were not
in Game one how do you think morale is
with the Rockets today
well it's good but can they be as
desperate and urgent after a win as they
were after a loss of course it's very
good they feel like us they're the team
with the best record in the league this
year they were not thinking they're a
speed bump on the way to the next
Warriors coronation and so they feel
good about themselves that they can make
this a good tough series and have their
chance to win it but can they be as
urgent and desperate as they were after
a loss and this is a team that has not
lost consecutive games since January
that hasn't lost consecutive games with
Harden and Paul playing since December
and so they bounce back from a loss
we'll see how they bounce back how they
come back after win the one thing I did
notice it felt like I thought they
needed to speed up tempo just a little
bit because they were getting burned
with these let me get something shot off
with two seconds on the shot clock or
three seconds or one second there that
get into the offense a little sooner and
I also think you know as great as Harden
and Paul are when you have contributions
get other people involved instead of
just standing around it just makes you
look more formidable I just don't know
how much you can rely on PJ Tucker
Trevor Ariza to have those kind of
performances Gordon I wouldn't be some
is dat but the other guys you know and
that's my big concern with Houston
you're gonna need somebody else to step
up besides Harden and Chris Paul how
consistent do you think that that other
you know the role players can be as we
move on in this series well they all
have to be what they were last night I
mean there was a career-high for PJ
Tucker between the two of them all over
they 17 of 19 there 60 of 18 I mean
you're not gonna have to do that but
Harden and Paul can shoot threes much
much better than they did and they the
Rockets need to get looped by muche
going again he's obviously really
struggling since coming back from the
shoulder injury the Rockets have things
they can do better as we thought about
the Warriors after Game one about the
Warriors they don't have to have career
nights as they did last night from PJ
Tucker into a degree Trevor Ariza
because they have other things they can
do better
the Rockets still I mean a mic so every
bit as much as they did in the in the
first game it was more recording than it
was in the first game and a little less
James Harden but there were the same
number of ISO plays in fact I think they
had one more last night so they didn't
really change what they do they did it
as you said with more force they did it
faster yeah they did it earlier in the
shot clock they did it in transition and
they can get that way if they're not
getting stops they do sometimes okay
take the ball out of the basket walk it
up
look things over you can't do that all
game they have to get out more quickly
so that when harden and Paul go
one-on-one and the defense reacts now
there's time for the pass and then the
next pass I mean that said you know last
night oh yeah they really move the ball
he had two more passes than they did in
Game one they are who they are and
they're fine with that
that they believe in who they are do you
think they're going to win the series
yeah you know I wouldn't think that I
think I put it this way since literally
since the preseason the Rockets the best
team this season the Warriors are among
the
best teams of any season and so you know
you you can't just now say alright they
won that game they win the sirs I
thought all along it would be a good
long series it can go if they can even
maybe get it back here for a game seven
which is pretty close to a toss-up but
you know until the champ is beat they
are the champs
do you have an MVP vote I don't vote any
longer I gave it up when some of those
rules changed and we influence salaries
and player availability wait we just
have too much power it went beyond a an
honor so I gave up my vote like I would
have voted for hardness you know what
rule specifically made you give up your
vote well it's the combination where our
salaries are now determined by where
some players can finish when you're
gonna get a supermax based on where you
were in the and say MVP voting or
all-nba voting well let's say the team
I'm covering wants to chase a free agent
if that free agent to be is somewhere in
the MVP voting his team can give him a
different contract than if he is not now
all of a sudden I got power to determine
whether the team I cover can can chase a
certain free agent it's not about the
people that I cover and oh I could have
given you a nice honor that you woulda
liked it's more about the business of
the NBA that as media we're supposed to
cover not influence and so I had an
editor who sort of grandfathered me in
four years he would have rather do we
not vote all along but you know I always
had so weak but when they made that
change I said okay you lives you know
I'm giving up the vote and I said the
NBA no saying to remove me we've had
James Harden on and you know he's can be
very engaging I don't know how he is to
the local media what kind of personality
is James Harden personalities a heart I
mean the funny thing about James and I
he and I have spoken about this he is
first a ball player that's where he's
had
you know he's happiest in the gym he's
happy talking basketball you know when
you on the rare chances that we actually
do talk we don't spend a lot of time
talking but we have on occasion as far
as he is to cover in the guy as he has
in other ways that you can see he has
grown so much but you know he's much
more available he's more forthright it's
got him mic threat like his game and
this sort of style in the spotlight he's
matured into it and so he's got he's
going from a tough guy to cover to a
pretty good one but always available you
know and that has developed in his years
here and so you know I enjoy covering
him I like it when he's particularly
honest with us like you know if you ask
a dumb question he'll give you a look
you know and it I enjoy the few times a
year we actually thought that's the one
thing that we've lost over the years in
covering the NBA if you go back to the
80s and 90s where you just sit and talk
to these guys a lot more than we do now
now everything the giant pack and James
is one of those that it would be good if
there was more times to talk without a
notebook without a recorder and because
he's an interesting guy he's good to
talk to but that's a rare thing in the
NBA as he studied the former greats like
scoring great to add to his game well
some of them most notably Kobe Kobe was
a hero and he has studied I mean besides
you know a kid in Los Angeles who hey
Kobe of course but he has studied that
sense and that's the one that just jumps
out at you but some not not a ton I
don't know that like if I brought up
Walt Frazier or something if he would
have a real feel for his style or what
his style would be now or any of that
kind of thing but you know he's sort of
of his generation so he studied the guys
that he followed as he developed into
the kind of player he is so not just as
a kid in Los Angeles but in the years
since but I don't know that he goes all
the way back to you know he knows Oscar
and his numbers but as he looked at old
tapes I wouldn't
so good stuff Jonathan we appreciate
your time safe travels and thanks for
joining us
always good talking to you that's a
Jonathan Fagan it covers the Rockettes
for the Houston Chronicle for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]